la onu teme un baño de sangre en mianmar
que tan inminente puede ser una guerra
civil en este país un día en argentina
si efectivamente ya llegamos más de 500
muertos según se estiman diversas
organizaciones derechos humanos y se se
ha acelerado el conflicto étnico con los
grupos armados que están en el interior
del país y el ejército no lo ha cesado
por el contrario ha aumentado la
velocidad de la represión ya no sólo una
represión en regla con en la calle entre
fuerzas de seguridad sino con grupos
paramilitares con grupos ilegales que
asesinan a personas en sus casas en su
lugar de trabajo así que el pronóstico
yo creo que es muy muy negativo y la
guerra civil está a la vuelta de la
esquina pero en este momento nos
enfrentamos a una de las peores matanzas
que está sufriendo el mundo la
actualidad ahora profesor como usted
también lo decía varias guerrillas
étnicas han amenazado unirse con las
protestas contra la junta militar sino
para las muertes de los civiles se
podría tener
una alianza que junte elementos tan
dispares como grupos armados de
distintas etnias y un movimiento de
protestas civiles
es posible que eso ocurra en la práctica
no creo que como un acuerdo explícito
pero mientras el ejército de miramar que
efectivamente es ese grupo mejor
preparado mejor armado financiará sus
programas por rusia con apoyo político
de china y eso siga así va a ser muy
difícil poder derrotarlo en el campo
quiero decir como como un elemento nada
más que el ejército mi hermana ha
bombardeado ha usado la fuerza aérea
para bombardear ciudades de minorías
étnicas grupos karen en la frontera con
tailandia y eso ha generado también
fuertes migraciones forzadas hacia el
país vecino entonces creo que también la
crisis de mi hermana está a punto de
generar un problema para la región ya no
solamente para su propio país ahora
varios países condenan la violencia de
esta junta militar y algunos imponen
nuevas sanciones que más se puede hacer
por parte de la comunidad internacional
para frenar esta crisis
yo creo que inmediatamente es que es
procede transacciones la onu tiene que
intervenir más fuertemente me parece que
los países tienen que intentar que
tienen que intentar los puede obligar
obviamente que tienen que intentar que
sus empresas dejen boicoteen las propias
se me amar y creo que también mente bien
una fuerte autocrítica de algunos grupos
como amnistía internacional alguna
prensa norteamericana por la forma en
que se han dedicado los últimos años en
socavar el liderazgo de sanssouci lo que
se ve ahora es claramente que estaba
haciendo equilibrio con un ejército que
era muy fuerte y así lo entendió también
la sociedad birmana que le dio el apoyo
electoral en las últimas elecciones
profesor usted la mencionaba y es un
punto clave en todo este conflicto que
pasará con aún san suu kyi que le depara
el futuro como lo ve
del futuro difícil vamos y no solamente
esta presa no sólo carece de posibilidad
de defenderse ni siquiera de estar
informada lo que pasa en el país como tú
has dicho pero yo creo que más a persona
una persona de más de 75 años o sea que
no tiene un futuro muy muy largo por
delante yo creo que los militares
también están jugando con esa
posibilidad los metales son son un
sector muy duro son un sector al que no
le importa mucho en la presión
internacional
importa mucho qué opina la gente de su
país entonces me parece que están
intentando alguna manera barrer con la
liderazgos a succi y generar una
democracia es tutelada donde aparezcan
un político propio a un ex militar que
pueda reconducir la situación pero esto
dentro de un año cuando ellos se
plantean recién en ese momento esas
elecciones